all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i have this idea right i have
this idea so the big talk of the town at
the moment is who this golden energy
person is now the two big prevailing
theories out there is that it's superior
iron man or it's maria rambo one thing i
also want to specify here we don't know
so anybody who's just like we know that
such and such they don't know right like
nobody knows we won't know until we
actually get a better look at that
person this is a really grainy shot you
only see it for a second or so uh so
it's difficult to tell who this person
is having said that
i want to go a different direction here
and there's actually a legitimate reason
why this is possible so while it could
very well be maria rambo right i don't
want to discount that or tony stark i
don't want to discount that either
although
it is kind of weird because when you
look at the images it looks like a black
person so unless tony stark just became
black i don't really see how that's the
case
[Laughter]
i want to go in the direction of this
potentially being
adam brashear now here's the thing like
before you write me off because i know a
lot of people are just going to be like
no not a chance no no no no here's the
thing right
hear me out on this because there's a
credible argument to be made here
that it could actually be the blue
marvel so for a lot of you all out there
who don't read comics you've probably
never heard of adam brashear this guy is
legit and he is so powerful it's not
even funny the guy's a living
anti-matter reactor what does it mean it
basically means he's powered by an
infinite source of energy right the guy
can essentially do almost anything he
wants to shy of like high-level reality
warping right it's like the only thing
you can't do but this guy is
ridiculously op uh so here's the thing
when you look at adam brashear the
possibility of this being adam beshear
is not based on his power right i'm not
basing that on his power he's incredibly
powerful how he would compare in the
marvel cinematic universe i don't really
know they shift things around all the
time for example they say that like
carol danvers as captain marvel is the
most powerful person in the universe
that has never been the case in the
history of marvel comics ever there's
never ever ever been an instance where
anybody said oh my god we're in trouble
let's go get carol danvers because she's
the most powerful person carol danvers
can just kind of punch hard and in fact
there was a really funny moment during
hikman's avengers new avengers when like
she fought the incredible hulk and was
just like hammering away right just
pounding on this guy and then when the
dust cleared the incredible hulk's just
laying there with his hands behind his
head and he's just like do you feel
better and then punches her into the
atmosphere right so there's never been
an instance where carol danvers has ever
been like the go-to person for power in
marvel comics except for maybe when she
was binary right when she had the power
of a white dwarf star but even then like
there were ample people out there that
were more powerful than she was so the
marvel cinematic universe plays by a
different set of rules that's the
important thing to understand right
powers do not necessarily scale from the
comics to the marvel cinematic universe
the way that we would expect them to the
reason why i would pick adam bashir here
is because of his capabilities so so for
those of you guys you've never heard of
adam burcher right to kind of kind of
wind this back a little bit those are
guys who have never heard of blue marvel
this guy's story is phenomenal so the
idea behind this is that blue marvel was
basically a superhero in the 1960s and
of course you had all the major issues
socio-political issues going on in the
us of the 1960s his arch nemesis was a
guy named connor sims and it was kind of
crazy this great big fight had broken
out between the two where literally it
had been a fight between blue marvel and
conor sims for quite some time uh but
ultimately adam beshear came out on top
but when he emerged from the rubble his
mask was torn and the country realized
he was a black guy and so on one side
you had black america who were like you
have to side with us you have to be on
our side you have to basically become
part of like the civil rights movement
so they wanted to turn him into more of
like a political figure you know and
sort of remove the humanity from him on
the other side you had like white folks
in the government who were terrified of
what would happen if you basically
turned against the federal government
and tried to destroy it and so president
kennedy called him into his office into
the oval office and was just like hey
man like you having these powers and
being a black guy people are concerned
now the response of adam bashir here is
look i'm not short-sighted right like i
am not a protector of like black america
or white america when a meteor the size
of arkansas came crashing down to earth
it's not as though it broke into a
million pieces and would only hit black
communities
it would destroy the entirety of
humanity i am a champion of the world
right this whole idea of like political
you know political divisions all that
kind of stuff that's you guys i've got
much bigger things to worry about than
that uh but the responsive kennedy was
be that as it may the country can't
handle this right now so he asks adam
bashir to step down which adam beshear
does and then kennedy gives him the
presidential medal of freedom and then
when adam beshear leaves the oval office
when he leaves the white house he
actually gets so mad that he throws his
metal now eventually he goes to the moon
because you know when you're a person
with superpowers you go to the moon to
relax and he's hanging out with uwatu
the watcher and the watchers like hey
man just so you know if that metal you
threw would hit the moon it would have
cracked it in half and adam's like i
mean i don't really care like i got more
important things to worry about now
eventually basically connor sims comes
back in the comics and uh like iron man
and carol danvers and like the century
robert reynolds who's just ridiculously
op ares the god of war right like
they're all fighting against conor sims
and he's just demolishing all of them
like it's absolutely ridiculous how
powerful that guy is and ultimately it
basically kind of goes down this rabbit
hole of like iron man trying to figure
out who the blue marvel is basically
tracking him down and you learn about
all this sketchy stuff the government
was doing even after adam beshear stood
down so like the whole idea behind like
project wide awake and all those things
all basically came because of adam
brashear it was it was just ridiculously
nuts but it was a phenomenal story but
here's the thing right if if this movie
doctor strange two right and this
potential character if this had popped
up like 10 years ago i would have said
okay yeah no way is adam for sure it'd
be cool but no there's no possibility
that it's him because adam versus hasn't
done anything significant right i mean
he had a really really cool origin story
he was brought back into the fold by
iron man he eventually led or at least
was part of the second iteration of the
mighty avengers alongside luke cage
monica rambo and all those guys which
was really really awesome but he did
some cool stuff uh but this in the more
recent years has changed entirely adam
bashir is not the kind of person that he
used to be in so far as the role he
plays in the larger superhero landscape
and here's what i mean by that right so
so let's remove the element of like his
powers from this equation right he is
very very very powerful he can do all
kinds of cool stuff but let's remove his
powers kind of circling back around to
the point we made before let's focus on
his capabilities the intelligence of
adam rasheer is way up there right the
things he works on in his base down in
the mariana trench because literally he
lives in the ocean where he can just be
removed from humanity and just be left
alone uh the stuff he builds down there
is light years ahead of anything that
like tony stark for example is working
on right the guy's got a genius level
intellect so much so that
depending on who you talk to in the
comic book community he's more
intelligent than like tony stark or
black panther right now take that to its
logical conclusion right in the comics
he led the ultimates so those you guys
who don't know the ultimates were
basically like the ultimate avengers
they were more of like a universal team
but they also functioned on a
multiversal level literally the first
thing this team did is they basically
overpowered galactus which was nuts the
roster of this team was just
ridiculously op right so you had adam
bashir you had america chavez you had
monica rambo carol danvers black panther
uh and i don't think there's anybody
else i think connor sims joined the team
at one point i feel like i'm missing
someone here but regardless it was a
very very overpowered team that was
ridiculously capable and adam beshear
led the team because he was the most
capable member out of everybody there
and in fact he was the one that figured
out that monica rambo is not a living
being anymore she's literally just
living energy like when that whole thing
happened where she gained her powers the
way that adam brashear sees her he sees
her as just like light in the form of a
human that basically monica rambo is
ridiculously overpowered right she's
just crazy like once she reaches her
full potential and she becomes like the
the totality of what she's capable of
adam beshear's whole idea is you'll be
the most powerful being in all of
creation because you're literally living
energy you can do anything you'll be
able to alter reality on like a
universal or even a multiversal scale
the power you have will just be
virtually unrivaled even by cosmic
standards right it's nuts but in terms
of intelligence the guy takes the cake
now that right there is basically reason
enough to be able to argue that could
very well be adam brashear because if
we're talking about this person who may
very well be maria rambo and i know
people are just like no rob isn't no it
is possible it's maria rambo right but
if we are talking about this idea that
it really is adam beshear if you're
talking about the illuminati the
illuminati is going to be composed of
people who are intelligent and capable
they don't they're not all rocket
scientists right doctor strange is cool
but he's not even as intelligent as like
iron man or reed richards or black
panther he's just a guy who can do some
magic stuff and it's cool he can pull a
rabbit out of a hat
right he can pull the end of the
multiverse out of his hat you know he's
he's capable right he's i mean doctor
strange is cool but in terms of
intelligence he just doesn't necessarily
have it but who are we missing when it
comes to the illuminati and we can
basically replace them with somebody who
is every bit as capable right chadwick
boseman passed away there is no t'challa
black panther and it'd be different if
we were talking about how chadwick
boseman was basically just like i'm
ready to take a break for some prolonged
period of time i don't want to make any
black panther movies for something like
you know five years uh but i'm down for
doing like a cameo then we get like
chadwick boseman as black panther from
some alternate reality or something like
that or potentially like you get michael
b jordan who returns his black panther
that's possible but if what marvel was
looking to do was move away from the
role of black panther with regards to
the illuminati right start this process
of giving us other people that are
somewhat black panther-esque insofar as
like representing the black community in
the mcu but not really giving us black
panther per se adam bershea is the best
person to do it the guy's ridiculously
powerful he's ridiculously intelligent
and i'm honestly kind of surprised up to
this point he never joined the
illuminati now the reason why he never
did in the comics is because when the
incursions were happening and the
collapse of the multiverse was taking
place and you had the illuminati who
were just kind of like gallivanting
around and destroying worlds in the end
adam beshear was very very similar to
black panther regarding the illuminati
in the sense that he never agreed with
the idea of it in the first place right
that all this information is kept
consolidated by a handful of people
because they have decided on their own
they're the only ones who should do that
which would be kind of an ironic thing
if you go into the mcu and he's a member
of the illuminati
but i would say i would i would i would
say given the what like the totality of
what makes adam bershea what he is his
intelligence his power his capability
the guy would be a huge asset on
something like the illuminati especially
from the scientific side now again
whether or not this is actually adam
brashear only time will tell and if they
were going to to introduce a
ridiculously obscure character like adam
brashear into the mcu the reality is
throwing him on the illuminati would be
the best way to do it because you
basically take someone that no one's
ever heard of and suddenly they're a
massively high profile person because
you have this guy who who people have
never heard of in their life next to
charles xavier and john krasinski's reed
richards and whoever else that we have
on the illuminati people are gonna be
like who is that guy right and then it's
just like i'm adam beshear i'm the blue
marvel i'm a genius right and then
people are like okay cool and then they
start looking him up right i mean it's
the iron man effect the marvel cinematic
universe had to convince people iron man
was not a robot when they first launched
the iron man movie most people didn't
know who he was we know who he is now
but back then he was basically obscure
to the non-comic book reader right there
were a lot of people they knew about
spider-man batman superman iron man was
not one of them and so you take that
concept you applied to someone obscure
like adam beshear it works right it's
just it's one of those cool things i
mean you see it across the board moon
knight is the exact same way she-hulk
people know of her but they know
virtually nothing about her it's just
one of those things that you just sort
of take as a grain of salt so i'd be
curious you know like monica rambo like
the marvel cinematic universe is filled
with superheroes who would be considered
incredibly obscure by the standards of
non-comic book readers so when you you
factor that in there's ample room here
so let me know what you guys think down
in the comments right do you think this
is just a ridiculous concept do you
think there's no way this is adam
brosher or do you think it's possible
that it could potentially be the blue
marvel that it could very well be that
guy who's been brought on to the
illuminati for any number of reasons and
we'll finally get to see him in the mcu
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace